J'ai adoré qu'approuvé de se réunir
et de paraître ringard à dire, mais nous étions plus
qu'une simple équipe, nous étions un groupe, nous
faisions ce film ensemble quand vous avez
un bel environnement confortable, alors
l'actrice pourrait aller sur Mars et revenir, nous
avons un environnement  ce qui est sûr ce qui
est attentionné si nous nous sentions libres de faire
ce que vous voulez être et nous sommes ensemble
jamais un risque critique si leurs
opinions et se réunissent en une véritable
équipe
chacune de ces trois personnes Sean bhavet
RDP et Patty Norris sont designer personnalisé
et Adam Stockhausen, notre
concepteur de production, étaient si critiques pour que ce film
se tienne debout,
elle est juste unique quand elle
ferait était de construire chaque plantation et d'obtenir des
échantillons de houle et de regarder la fin de
chaque fondation là où il y a une certaine
quantité de détails dans lesquels elle est entrée  il
ne va pas s'asseoir ici vous êtes à l'
endroit réel où quelque chose se passe alors chaque
image que vous configurez a une vérité ce
film il devait juste se sentir vrai mais il
devait aussi se sentir b  beau, nous ne
voulions pas superposer les horreurs de l'esclavage
avec le genre de saleté et de boue et
tout le reste parce que la réalité est que
les lieux sont vraiment assez
solides et qu'il serait inutile de le faire
mal paraître c'est simplement le contraste
entre la beauté de  la nature dans laquelle
ils ont tous existé et l'horreur du
monde et des vies qu'ils ont à
vivre Steve tourne très très simplement
avec Sean et souvent il laisse
respirer les choses ça ne veut pas dire que c'est
toujours lent parce que ce n'est pas qu'il y a un
tension qui est très très soigneusement
gérée et il y a beaucoup d'exemples
où un plan est tenu longtemps et je pense que
cela donne juste au public le temps de
vraiment ressentir les choses et de développer une
relation avec le film qu'il n'est
pas autorisé à faire quand vous le bombardez
avec des images, vous notez quelque chose que j'ai fait comme
indiqué s'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
c'est faux avec l'instruction Adam
Stockhausen
il est juste talentueux et tout est question de
détail de lui et de la sensation qu'il est un
artiste et tout comme les loges de Paddy, nous avons
examiné beaucoup de plantations, puis
nous l'avons réduit pour savoir notre poignée
que nous tournons réellement. Je suis le
dieu d'Abraham, le dieu d'Isaac et le
dieu de la plantation de Jacob Points, il
appartient toujours à  une famille qui travaille dans l'
agriculture et ils ont en fait trouvé de la
canne à sucre qui est un serviteur qui n'obéit pas à
son Seigneur sera battu de plusieurs
coups c'est l'Écriture La plantation d'Epps
ressemble également beaucoup à une ferme en activité
mais est très graveleuse et c'est très
difficile là-bas et tout juste  senti très
gris et très rugueux allons là-haut
George Turner pour la saison La plantation de Turner se
sent très à l'abri
et toute la sensation de l'endroit est moins
vaste et plus isolée demain matin
maître sha maître Simha pour se retirer mesquin
mon approche et la plantation de Shaw est en
quelque sorte  de ce soulagement pour Patsy où
elle est traitée comme un être humain et
c'est magnifique, ils avaient tous leur propre
identité et nous avions une
séparation visuelle entre  eux le look du
film et le look du décor et regardez
les clients pour moi, tout consistait
à être connecté à Solomon et donc
tout a aidé ce voyage pour moi
et m'a juste permis d'avoir une sorte de
chemin dans ce monde, j'ai senti que  très
profondément si vous voulez survivre faites et dites
le moins possible
mais je ne veux pas survivre je veux
vivre nous sommes ensemble nous nous connaissons
il y a une sorte de communauté alors alors
vous vous connectez aux acteurs n'agissez jamais à
risque  de partager leurs avis et de se
regrouper comme une vraie équipe c'est super
vous